welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about who in the
mcu is best equipped to beat up a
grieving magic mama who just lost her
entire family because that's how you
should beat up just kidding don't do
that
my name's empty and i'm here today with
my big head gang brother mommy [ __ ]
peaches and cream grieving magic mama
was my favorite grateful dead record oh
my god start to finish
breathing magic mama up on a hill
agreement magic mama who did she kill
oh 17 hours 17 hours that record is
triple platinum yeah that's crazy you're
right
yeah i kept my virginity at a grateful
dead concert let's uh
let's move on
what a president
hit me with that big question tommy you
got it as the marvel cinematic magical
multiverse continues to expand i'm so
excited for what comes next for our
favorite heroes especially scarlet witch
as we anxiously await her next major
appearance in doctor strange of the
multiverse of madness you got me
thinking about this week's big question
who will wander maxum off battle in the
upcoming doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
oh [ __ ] that's a good question tom i'm
glad you asked because after the massive
blow up our girl wanda maximoff aka the
scarlet witch received during wand
division we can't wait to see what she
gets up to next because she's got all
these powers now i mean she she changed
her wardrobe from sweatpants to a whole
getup with a tiara i mean i wish i could
do that i just she had me feeling
feelings of that outfit i was
very attractive i hate her yes but who
is wanda going to face off against in
doctor strange too like is she going to
be more of an antagonist in this story
causing chaos across the multiverse as
she bends reality in an effort to bring
her family back together or will she
ultimately work with doctor strange to
bring the multiverse back to a place of
stability following the events of loki
and the upcoming spider-man no way home
so we're going to take a look at
everything that we already know about
the upcoming film parse through some of
the rumors that are floating around out
there and finally present some theories
of our own to see if we can figure out
who wanda might battle against in the
next film i hope it's diddy kong and or
samus from um uh super smash brothers
but you know who knows
[Music]
i hope it's cranky kong oh my god yes i
feel like cranky kong is a good matchup
for one of those all-powerful that
cranky guy i'm
i'm going to go ahead and use words to
yogurt for me i'm a sip for cranky kong
oh you're a simple cranky god i mean
that cane
super sexy it's got you smiling like
that frankie come
on things
oh my god everybody this will be your
one and only spoiler warning in case any
of these rumors or predictions just
happens to be true so if you don't want
to know anything or any possibilities
about doctor strange two you better
leave because we're gonna be talking
about some stuff okay we're gonna be
speculating it's a speculation nation
and as we start to think of potential
opponents let's begin with who we know
is already confirmed to be in doctor
strange's multiverse of madness and we
have to start off with the most obvious
of all these choices
dr strange big news everybody i ran into
kevin feige at a nearby urinal and he
confirmed to me that doctor strange will
be in doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness you heard it here first
exclusive you scuba that's a big scoop
normally you can talk to the urinal so
this is big this is real big oh yeah
i'm chatty i'm a chatty in a men's room
that's i've always been a little bit
talkative but yeah i'm sure he and wanda
are definitely gonna have some type of
magic throw down because it's obvious
it's like it's gonna happen if it
doesn't happen i'm gonna be really upset
because one is kind of crazy and doctor
strange is in charge of keeping crazy
magic in check so we also know that wong
is gonna be there shocker and i love my
boy benedict wong working as much as
humanly possible whether he's playing
kublai khan or a scientist in the
martian or basically he gets to be in
any marvel movie he wants these days or
property he if he says he wants to be in
it he's in it the point is this man
works he works all day every day wong's
making money moves that's what he said
right i follow him on instagram he just
tells pictures of money all day
yeah i don't know how he makes all that
money no he's probably making the money
all that money off of those fights that
he's rigging in
yeah he's kidding abomination or just
i'm sorry there was a million best parts
of that movie but that was one of my
favorite parts all right who else who
else are we looking at we'll definitely
be seeing mordo and doctor strange too
because the character has been confirmed
to return and really there's no way that
his quest to rid the world of sorcerers
wouldn't bring him into direct conflicts
with the most magical woman in the
universe the scarlet witch he's going to
definitely want to you know stop her or
just take some of that power or just
manage it for himself because he doesn't
like source words or sources
it's very equal opportunity mordo is my
lead candidate to either be
the person who
after dr strange two
shows up in a ton of things like like
not his own show but as like you know
maybe an adversary or anti-hero kind of
almost like an agatha harkness type
character and a tv show or
to die and doctor strange two would
never be heard from again
i don't think there's any middle ground
we're either getting way more of that
character or it's just going to be
that's going to be it it would be such a
shame to waste she would tell so i hope
that he's one of my favorite actors but
i
but he could yeah he could 100 percent
die because he could be defeated
and he's had to wait like four years to
play this character again he's gonna
want to get back seriously i really hope
that he just they set him up to be this
like really annoying magical force in
the mcu like he is in the comics
absolutely absolutely oh we also know
we're getting a new character in this
movie uh who we know for sure it's gonna
appear and that's america
chavez yes we have america chavez we
already have confirmation that this
character will be in the film portrayed
by actress sochi gomez
that's exciting but will she face off
with wanda directly because if she does
she'll certainly put up a good fight in
the comics america chavez has superhuman
strength and speed she could fly and
most importantly she could kick open
holes in reality in order to travel
through the multiverse which if the
multiverse is madness that's going to be
a helpful skill as an interdimensional
being from a utopia parallel she might
be the perfect hero to stop a nexus
being like wanda or at least
maybe knock her back into the right side
of the law
you know hell yeah yeah america chavez
she is no slouch that girl box
all day so like if anyone i feel like
she could definitely give wanda around
for her money like hardcore yeah i love
america it's like you don't know i'm so
excited to see her in doctor strange too
because i've been clamoring for america
chavez to appear in the mcu for so long
she's so cool guys so cool but anyways
now that we have all the confirmed
appearances covered let's get to some of
the more fun theories and rumors out
there because one rumor involves the
potential appearance of check this out
tommy the illuminati in the mcu no
i'm not talking about the shadowy
organization of cloaked lizard people
who secretly control everything that
happens in this world in real life
because that's a 100 what's happening
it's definitely jay-z it's definitely
george w bush it might be uh jojo siwa i
don't know i heard rumors it's jojo for
sure it's that kid who yodeled in the
walmart
yeah in the marvel comics the illuminati
are a secret group of heroes that formed
after the big cree scroll war and they
worked to pull the strings behind the
scenes and shape the status of the
superhuman world and the original
arrangement of the illuminati in the
comics are the following folks we got dr
strange iron man mr fantastic tesseracts
the mermaid man what black bolt the man
who doesn't say [ __ ] the illuminati was
a team of heroes that basically just
decided these big world-changing
decisions
in this like little tree house and not
telling anybody what they're doing like
it's some really messed up [ __ ] but
these people have to exist to stop the
big threats threats like the incursions
that are definitely coming to the mcu
like the multiversal incursions where
universes collide and there's this big
secret war scenario and in some
iterations there were also more
villainous characters attached to the
illuminati like dr doom and magneto you
know i'm waiting for dr doom baby so yes
let us cover some of these people to see
if there are any strong contenders to
appear in doctor strange too starting
with mr iron man because tony stark
famously wiped out thanos and his army
and end game with the infinity stones
sacrificing himself in the process don't
know if you missed that part in end game
it's a very big part uh if you missed it
you should probably watch it again tony
stark's dead spoilers i highly doubt
that we'll be seeing iron man again
anytime soon but there could potentially
be a tony stark from another universe or
timeline that could come in to face
wanda but i doubt that they would be so
quick to bring
robert downey jr back so soon after they
just gave him this amazing send-off but
we do know that ruby williams is coming
to the mcu soon through her iron heart
tv show but i doubt that she'll be ready
to take on wanda as iron heart in time
for doctor strange too but you never
know i mean black women they're pretty
strong so who knows she could she could
do it i think so also i don't know if
you knew this tommy but if you go back
to that court scene from iron man 2 when
we first didn't introduce to don cheadle
war machine on tony stark's phone he
does have an app for the illuminati
there's an app for that there's an app
for that there was an app for conspiring
in secrets as the illuminati excellent
pretty big news i like that right you
heard it here probably not first but i
heard it very recently and it blew my
mind hey
that's another empty scoop call him
baskin-robbins he's scooping 31
different items today all right mr
fantastic reed richards himself could be
showing up here i would throw his
chances of an appearance in these small
but maybe category fantastic four are
coming to the mcu we know that and one
way they could make their appearance is
by crossing over from a different
universe rather than doing a traditional
origin story in the main mcu timeline
which i don't really know that we need
again i mean one of the reasons that
made the new spider-man so good is that
they just treated the audience like they
weren't complete morons that needed to
be spoon-fed another peter parker being
bit by a spider they're like you know
how he becomes spider-man if wanda's
actions wind up having some negative
effect on reed richard's home dimension
he could use that big old brain to cross
dimensions to tell his neighbors next
door to keep it down with all the chaos
magic threatening his reality he's got a
baby at home maybe i don't know that
baby might be king the conqueror or she
is because you're a little princess
we don't know we never know
franklin richards ah it would be an
exciting way to introduce to marvel's
first family in the mcu i'll tell you
that and his bob wants to say yeah
you're my wonder woman wonder woman call
me mr fantastic call me mr fantastic
stop now think about it
now think about it and when i thought
about it i said it doesn't make sense
because wonder woman is dc and mr
fantastic is mcu so that's my scoop is
that b.o.b doesn't know his comics he
also believes that the earth is flat um
the earth is flat in your mind i mean
what's the whole deal explain i think
it's flat and it's round
i did hear that
b.o.b is a very interesting person with
very interesting views target stewart
it's flat and it's round like uh
you ever you know you ever like had a
bowl of popcorn okay um
like the bowl was flipped upside down
speaking of reed richards dr doom is
another member of the illuminati that in
the same way as mr fantastic could show
up to fight wanda in this reality and
potentially for the same reasons as reed
richards but maybe in an effort to
control her and use her powers for his
own personal gain so yeah he definitely
has a small chance and we also have to
consider secret wars because doctor doom
played a huge role in that multiversal
secret wars event from 2015. so if the
fantastic four are slated to come to the
mcu very soon we could see doctor doom
mess with wanda steal her powers and
then kick off a secret war scenario but
that's all just speculation what's that
next we have namor
aka the submariner
now watch me whip now watch me name more
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow this might be my corniest episode
[Music]
i'm definitely not uh i'm not upping my
street cred with teenagers today but uh
who needs to i'm an old man i don't need
to fraternize with them anyway
everyone's flipping the name or dude
that's right
now we whip whip no watch me name her
how we do it namor would be an
absolutely wild character to battle
wanda but i highly doubt that we're
gonna see him and doctor strange too if
anything it seems more likely that we're
going to see the mermaid man in
wakanda forever due to his historically
contentious link to wakanda namor is
technically a mutant in the comics as is
scarlet witch but they do have a bit of
history especially in the house of m's
storyline i just doubt that namor would
show up to fight wanda here and i just
don't see this being his first
foray and he would get laid out like
daymore is strong like don't get me
wrong neymar is he will mess you up but
not against wanda he would get
ringed out immediately
yeah sure sure sure but next up we have
the king of all the inhumans mr
blackbolt himself and that is yes you
know a definite no right there all right
then no need to talk about it
so marvel has kind of already given us
black bulb through the one season of the
humans tv show that we will never speak
up again but i doubt that we'll be
seeing black bolts in the mcu anytime
soon because the inhumans tv show didn't
really go all that well and like the
inhumans are pretty much retconned out
of the mcu i doubt that we'll be seeing
black bolt in um in an illuminati
scenario this soon anyway but we who
knows we could get the humans down the
line but it seems that the inhumans
aren't on marvel studios plate speaking
of mutants coming to mcu including one
i'm very much looking forward to
magneto showing up to fight wanda would
be an incredible surprise i mean who
wouldn't love that in the comics magneto
is the father of scarlet witch wanda
maximoff we don't need more
we already know that's right that's
right they've obviously changed that in
the mcu but it would be so cool if
magneto showed up to battle his daughter
from another universe
a small chance yes but we can't ever
discount it you could never say never
say never when the writers never say
never when it comes to magneto i mean he
did use wanda max above to create a
whole reality um in the comics so like
who says that he won't just pop into our
reality be like hey that wanda's pretty
good are you using her because we'll
i'll take him yes i would love that
wanda there's a costco of different
universal wandas now just buy one yes
so yeah a lot of the traditional
illuminati from the marvel comics don't
really seem to fit the profile of
characters that could face wanda in
doctor strange too however there is a
rumor out there that the illuminati are
being readjusted for the mcu and this
new mcu version of the illuminati is
rumored to be
professor x captain carter monica rambo
aka spectrum mordo which is kind of
crazy and balder the brave which is even
crazier than mordo to me so let us go
through these potential options starting
with professor x because there are
rumors swirling that at least one mutant
will appear in doctor strange too which
makes sense because we did have that
quick silver tige in one division which
is what happens right before doctor
strange two and what better foil for
wanda than the omega level telepath
mutant professor x because he might be
the only one possibly in the multiverse
maybe capable of stopping wanda by
invading her mind and just battling her
in there because that's where he's on
equal level that's where he can walk
around in the mind he gets legs of the
mind handsome man that james mcavoy
[Laughter]
and what a groovy mutation it is but the
big question is would they bring over
james mcavoy from the fox marvel
universe or just recast professor x
completely i think there's a really
strong possibility that if we are going
to get a mutant in doctor strange too
it's going to be the big brain in the
chair if these rumors are true and there
are going to be some fox x-men showing
up in doctor strange 2 who else would
you like to see like i i personally
would love to see jean grey pop up
because i feel like a jean grey versus
wanda fight would be nuts oh no my oh my
god like a phoenix jean grey versus
wanda would be crazy what even happened
there would be it would be like a global
catastrophe wherever whatever planet
they were on would be destroyed i think
the whole solar system honestly that
they were in would just be gone
who else we got tommy well we also have
captain carter my girl
showing up uh kevin carter showing up is
a very interesting possibility we
haven't quite finished the what if
series at the time we're recording this
but the first episode showed us a
timeline where peggy carter took the
super soldier serum instead of steve
rogers if the what if shows show us that
captain carter can cross the multiverse
then there's some potential we could see
her and doctor strange too teasers have
shown us that apparently captain carter
and strange supreme are confirmed to
meet up later on in the series could
that lead her to the multiverse of
madness also would she transition into
live action if they bring back haley
atwell to be captain carter would she be
powered up or could it really end up
being sharon carter
on her own super soldier serum taking
the name captain carter
oh my god because i guess that would
make sense considering that sharon
carter has had that you know that
walmart super soldier serum in the
winter soldier yeah like why wouldn't
the power broker want to empower herself
because we do see in the comics that
power broker two is he chose to empower
himself with powers why not sharon
carter sharon carter could easily be
captain carter in this event sharon
carter the party starter let's go
yes
the party started literally she's just
hosting parties all day is it gonna be
sharon carter or is it gonna be aaron
carter because either way the universe
is in good hands more than anyone on
this list monica rambo knows what wanda
maximoff is capable of and i also think
that she has the strongest possibility
of showing up in dr strange too because
we know that we're going to see monica
again in the marvels but could she show
up before then to face wanda because
with her powers incredibly juiced up
from those traversals through that hex
force field in one division she might
now be strong enough to take wanda on
because we saw how she defied being
squashed like a bug in one division she
was like nope you can't slam me on the
ground because i got powers now i would
love that
speaking of things i would love i would
love to now share
a wild rumor with you this one is pretty
crazy but uh as we mentioned before the
new illuminati could include balder the
brave
balder has yet to appear in the mcu in
the comics balder is the son of odin and
half brother of thor
his death was part of the prophecy that
would lead to ragnarok so to avoid that
odin ordered free god to use the magic
to make boulder invulnerable from harm
which feels unfair he's also stronger
and faster than most asgardians much
like me and would make a formidable
fighting companion to thor
perhaps he'll reveal to be an ass
guardian from another multiverse or
maybe uh just yet another sibling that
odin didn't tell thor about or loki you
know kind of like a ongoing episode of
maury povich just family secrets
revealed
all the time even after both
sit down
i have another child but it doesn't
really seem like he's poised to make an
appearance in dr strange too
since it's coming up before thor love
and thunder this one probably has a
small chance of coming to fruition there
are some other possibilities for
rwanda's uh opponents out there though
especially those with magical abilities
much like wanda herself so let's run for
you a few other possible theories i
think one of those people has got to be
agatha harkness
exactly the harkness yeah yeah agatha
harkness has got to be a top contender
juana did leave her as a prisoner of her
own mind and the pta in west view but
there is no way that she stays there
forever that would be a waste because
she's just too good she's just too good
and catherine hahn is a whole queen we
stand captain han that's on this channel
that's right exclusively it's gonna be
only catherine hahn videos from here on
out absolutely i have a new series
coming out
tom on hand
but yeah maybe marvel didn't know just
how well the character would be received
when they were originally planning one
division but i am certain that if they
hadn't already planned to have agatha
reappear in doctor strange too they've
definitely changed their mind or at
least considered changing their mind
since then because everyone loves zack
of the darkness she's literally the
backbone of the mcu come on but whether
agatha figures out a way out of westview
on her own or she is pulled out of there
by someone else she has to show up to
face wanda again in doctor strange too i
feel because
that's i don't know that she was a match
for one and one division why not right
maybe she's the only one that can absorb
all that chaos magic she also is aware
more than wanda is of wanda's abilities
you know
she's she's more
in tune with what wanda can do so she
might be able to
use that knowledge against her this is
true and she has like uh who knows how
long it was worth of familiarity with
the darkhold which talks all about wanda
and like she's probably knows more about
wanda than wanda knows about herself
next we have uh something very familiar
to me something i experience almost
every night nightmare might be appearing
in uh
in this movie when we last saw wanda
studying the dark hold we heard the
voices of her hex children billy and
tommy call to her from somewhere beyond
just before what looked like red eyes
flashed on the screen but whose eyes
were watching wanda could those eyes
belong to
nightmare northwest
one million dollars uh we've already
seen one fearlord appear as the dweller
in the darkness in shangxi nightmare
could appear to try and consume wanda's
powers or prey upon her grief over
losing tommy and billy because that's
what fearlord loved to do like to prey
on grief and fear those [ __ ] when
woo was like yeah i gotta go get my wife
from behind this dragon scale wall even
though very clearly bad things are
happening i'm blind to it grief is
blinding but what is grief and love
humans were coming out of the cracks
what is grief if not demons devouring
the souls of your friends and co-workers
as you try to find your wife that's all
that's exactly what vision said in one
division that's true it's true
honestly but what is grief
if not demons devouring the souls of
your friends and co-workers as you try
to find your wife
but no
that's a that's a really good one i
never really considered nightmare but we
also have to consider loki and or silvie
and or the tva and or
kang because after the events of the
loki series it seems plausible that any
multiverse shenanigans that come up in
doctor strange 2 would attract the eye
of loki sylvie what's left of the tva
and most importantly kang kang gang and
there are some rumors that loki and or
silvi will appear in the film but would
that be too much because it seems like
kang is the next big villain in the mcu
so who do you think realistically mt who
who's your pick
to click who's absolutely gonna be in
this movie if you if you were a betting
man
hmm i would say that in terms of like
who's going to be in this movie that's
going to be facing wanda i would say
dormammu is a really big big pic because
i know we didn't talk about dirmamoo
here but like i feel like because their
mama was introducing doctor strange one
and darmamu was like all right i won't
mess with your reality now but i'm gonna
find a way i just feel like he just he
wants revenge against doctor strange
yeah he wants to break that bargain real
bad so he might want to try to bargain
with wanda and wanda and and obama might
have to just go head to head no does
benedict cumberbatch play
the
fightable version of dormammu or like
that's what i'm wondering because he was
i mean i would hope so he played her
mommy the first time all right that's
what i wanted or do they cast another
actor i hope not who do i think listen
two things
i don't know who she's gonna be facing
off with i do think that professor x is
gonna debut in this movie professor x
might be charged with clearing her mind
you know what i mean like she might be
so far with the grief and the the
madness element of the title in getting
her family back that she does lose her
mind and that charles may be tasked with
being the one person in that current
universe that can
make her kind of see straight again
sober her up for lack of a better word
you'll get her thinking clearly so i can
see a mental conclusion but i could
definitely also see a physical battle
between mordo and wanda resulting in
my more recently predicted death of
mordo although i hope not either that or
strengthening of of mordo's presence
which is what i hope in the mcu you know
like that fight kind of up upping him to
as they say in wrestling a main eventer
on the card so yeah i think it's uh
charles xavier and mordor are my two
predictions oh my god like immorto is
definitely going to be facing off
against wanda at some point and like
he's probably going to have some type of
trick off his sleeve to be a match for
wanda and i cannot wait to see what that
is because he's up to something he is up
to something yes don't know what it's
been and honestly in the timeline of the
mcu it's been a long time since we've
seen mordo because like it's 2023 now
and dr strange one happened in like what
2015 so like he's been making moves also
he didn't help for him he did not help
take down family he was like you're on
your own he's like you guys you guys
messed up the time stone you're dead to
me now son don't touch that time stone
you're dead to me yeah but that is it
for our first question of the day but
before we move on if you haven't already
seen it you should head on over to
newrockstarsmerch.com to check out their
new morris shirt inspired by the lovable
furry character from chungchi and the
legend of the ten rings it's an awesome
looking shirt and while you're there
also grab a latest obsession shangshi
tea some of the shang chi stickers and
any of the loki suicide squad or what if
merch we got all sorts of merch for your
nerd needs grabbing something from d
rockstars.com is an awesome way to
support this channel and to show the
world your love for your favorite fandom
and before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from some of
the people that helped bring us big
question to you people like draftkings
it's been a great start to the nfl
season and it's only getting better at
draftkings the official daily fantasy
partner of the nfl and draftkings is
putting new customers in the center of
the action with a free shot at millions
of dollars in total prizes so get in on
the action right now it's simple just
pick your lineup stay under the salary
cap and see how your team stacks up
against the competition and feel the nfl
action like never before with a free
shot at millions of dollars in total
prizes and draftkings is safe secure and
reliable and the best part is you can
deposit and withdraw your cash whenever
you want download the draftkings app now
and use code big question and this week
new customers can get a free shot at
millions of dollars in total prizes so
enter code big question to get a free
shot at millions in total prizes with
your first deposit that's code big
question only at draftkings the official
daily fantasy partner of the nfl minimum
five dollar deposit required eligibility
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
for details if you dread looking at your
credit card statements you're not alone
i personally hide my credit card
statements like that enchanted book in
evil debt that turns people into ghoul
monsters i just don't look at them debt
can feel crippling but upstart can help
you on your path to financial freedom
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan and
it's all done online in the internet
with those confusing tubes al gore
invented whether it's paying off credit
cards or consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses take
that trip to the czech republic you
deserve it over half a million people
have used upstart to get one fixed
monthly payment and god knows i may be
one of them after this because i want to
go to the czech republic upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
and is expanding access to affordable
credit unlike other lenders upstart
considers your income and current
employment to find you a smarter rate
for your loan and since i work at new
rockstars business is going to be
booming for me when upstart gets a hold
of my records with a five minute online
rate check you can see your rate up
front for lows between 1 000
and 50 000
what a span imagine if you get the 1 000
you must really suck but the 50 000
you're doing everything right you can
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan that's
faster than getting your photos
developed at a at a pharmacy find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com big question that's
upstart.com
big question don't forget to use our url
to let them know we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to
upstart.com
bigquestion well thank you tommy well
now it is time for our bite size
questions and our first bite size
question of the day is tommy
scrolls cast or learn magic and this is
from dm orphan meat on discord thank you
dm morphin
i never had over me before but uh
probably never will in theory anyone in
the marvel universe should be capable of
learning and practicing a form of magic
especially eldritch magic my personal
favorite from my d d character garacus
bright a tiefling warlock in the mcu
doctor strange showed us how someone
with enough determination
could study spell books and learn how to
practice spells
and perform magic i don't know why i
stopped talking we also know that
aldrich magic can be performed by both
human and alien species we saw krugar a
labyrinth do some eldritch magic in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2
post-credit scene but what about our
shape-shifting friends the skrulls can
they become masters of the mystic arts
when a scroll copies the likeness of
someone else they're not able to copy
their powers in the infamous secret
invasion run in marvel comics some had
to use technology to replicate the true
hero's abilities now that's just
resourceful however there are
super skrulls who along with
shape-shifting abilities do have their
own enhanced abilities there are also
war scrolls that can copy powers these
types of skrulls also made an appearance
during the secret invasion all roads
lead back to that secret invasion baby
just say secret invasion and people on
the internet will go ah yeah
all roads lead back to that secret
invasion baby
[Music]
what about magic
i'm talking street magic david blaine
close up illusion no i'm not
close-up magic your power exceeds that
of the sorcerer supreme i learned that
what happens do we have of the scrolls
using magic when they were trying to
improve the creation of super scrolls
the squirrels used a combination of
science and magic
some scrolls have evolved into dire race
by studying black magic diuretics can
shapeshift and use magic we also know of
both
knox possibly the greatest scroll
sorcerer of all time as well as skrull
sorcerer klobach of course knox and
klobuck which sound like klingon skrulls
are capable of learning and using magic
if one got good enough at it they could
potentially imitate the sorcerer supreme
himself dr steven strange oh shoot i
would love to see a skrull strange i
love how you brought up the dire race
because the dioramas are one of my
favorite villains in the comics because
in particular they are rom villains like
i don't know if you know about rom space
night the owner of space night volume
one oh me too did we just become best
friends yep i saw one at like a comic
con i was like i have to buy it this i'm
not not gonna buy this absolutely um but
no rom space night is just really cool
and like the space nights of galador if
i'm not mistaken are owned by marvel
studios i would love to see the space
nights appear and the dire wraiths and
see that struggle appear in the mcu
sometimes hit me with that uh second
bite-sized question tom absolutely we
have another question does captain
marvel have a home base or ship or does
she go from one intergalactic airbnb
emergency to another that was asked by
queen of dupont
on discord oh queen of dupont oh queen
of the pun but yeah where does captain
marvel go in between missions like does
she keep an apartment on holla and
perhaps a condo on xandar if there are
any xendarian condos left because thanos
probably just destroyed that i think
they've all been bought by billionaires
bezos buying up all the lambs
does she secretly sneak back to earth to
hang out in paris or milan from time to
time who knows so we can't say for
certain where carol divers likes to hang
out in the mcu when she's not
uppercutting titans but the comics have
answered this very question because in
captain marvel number nine released in
2019 it's revealed that carol denver's
has a secret underground base hidden
underneath a lake in harpswell sound
maine it's very similar in appearance to
the bat cave and it's next to her family
home and possibly stephen king i don't
know it's maine
is a very big stephen king spot maine
loves stephen king maybe it's new dairy
maine and pennywise but now given that
the mcu version of captain marvel has a
little bit of a different backstory than
the comics i doubt that we'll discover a
hidden captain marvel lair in maine
unfortunately but
you never know but i think the idea of
her taking over a warship that she
procured from some evil forces that she
defeated out there in the universe is
way cooler than the under the lake
getaway thing anyway so
yeah let's just go with that marvel
studios let's just do that
just jack a warship and just use and
repurpose it why not well now it's time
for my favorite part of the show it's
time for the box of scraps
but today's box of scraps question is
tommy if you were part of the illuminati
yeah how would you want to control the
world simple simple mt thank you for
asking me i would dispatch an army of
the most vicious cairns ever known to
man
there would be no retail store that
would be safe
no neighborhood park
that would be inhabitable
no place where you could ever be feel
safe from the wrath of a concerned karen
did you have the audacity to go to
barnes noble while not being white my
karen's will handle you
did you
did you pull out of a parallel parking
spot just a little too close to my karen
and her subaru crosstrek my parents will
end up here did you get
on an airplane and have the audacity to
wear your mask the entire time my
currents will be there to take their
masks put them under their nose as they
eat walnuts too slow never fully wearing
a mask the entire time and on their
death beds as they are ravaged with
covet 19 my karens will whisper master
thomas the illuminati will never die
as long as there is a caring breathing
uh
that's how i would do it wow not to get
political what would you do mt hey man
that's a pretty
amazingly scary world
full of carrots yes and they all get
that haircut too that may i speak to the
manager oh my god i get to see them all
on the illuminati table with the same
haircut it's just like how should we
ruin the world
let me see how much i can replicate it
right now bang swoop down oh my god
let's do it
bobby with the carriage excuse me
excuse me i have been waiting at the
deli counter for three minutes okay
you've let everyone get in front of me i
need to get my boar's head salami i need
to get my wisconsin sharp cheddar and my
horseradish mustard before i [ __ ]
lose it well that was a quite the uh
scenario but if i were part of them how
would i try to control the world i i
would probably just honestly just try to
stop global warming as much as i can
because like no one else is gonna do it
i'll just be like a mini like i guess
like a weird like not like thanos a mini
thanos would just be thanos i'm out of
here
well done i don't know how i would do it
but i would just use my illuminati just
to stop global warming
you'd be doing nice things it's not me
i'd be shutting down
street festivals i'd be
i'd be asking for permits on every
corner
yeah i'd be like the karen gestapo king
karen i'm the king of carrots
neal before me i am the king of kerins
king of karen's on cbs starring kevin
james this year he'd like to speak to
the manager she is the manager can they
ever figure it out kevin james is the
king of karen's always arms crossed
well that is it for this episode of big
question i want to thank tommy beck told
my big head gang brother for joining me
this episode you can follow tommy at
tommybechtold on twitter you can follow
me at mastertainment on twitter if you
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but
most importantly you can follow new
rockstars on twitter because tyler's
doing some amazing [ __ ] on there also
you can follow us on youtube and when
you do hit that notification bell so you
can get notifications whenever we upload
a video and uh and just as an aside
tyler please stop asking me to submit to
a dna test those rumors aren't true you
have to stop listening to philip
uh anyway go ahead
thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you